certainly going to be a proud moment for
all laker nation later tonight ring
night for the lakers as they take on the
clippers in game two of our double
header and uh i know somebody else who's
pretty pumped about that 17th
championship and he joins us
now snoop how are you kid what's
happening rna
how are you what side you got around
your neck man oh man i got my laker
championship
trophy man number 17. you understand me
had to go give me one i'm waiting on my
ring i'm gonna see if genie and i'm
gonna give me one
what did it mean to you to watch that
you know it was such a strange season
coming down to the bubble last year and
uh
eventually the lakers hoisting the
trophy
what were your fondest recollections of
that run
i mean that run brought it brought the
whole city of ballet together because
like you said we were going through a
global pandemic and you were dealing
with a lot of social injustices
but it's just something about that team
and that the way they played the way
they came together the way they stuck
together the way they fought together
they represented everybody in the la you
know in la county so we felt like that
was our victory we felt like we was out
there with them and they did a great job
by you know sticking together and
bringing home that gold fight
that larry o'brien snoop last year was
such a
peak in valley for number one nba family
i can't imagine what it was like as an
la fan you we go from losing kobe bryant
to a pandemic and the lakers winning the
championship
that has to be i know first this is the
craziest thing we've ever lived through
this pandemic but
like i say to start out losing coping
that was traumatic for la fans
and nba fans then to finish it off with
a championship how crazy was it
last year for you i mean it was an
emotional rollercoaster but
one thing i can say to show is that god
don't make no mistakes and i feel like
it's all his plan and you know to put us
through so much and then to give us that
you know joyful moment at the end of the
year you know it's
it's a blessing in disguise so we're
just thankful that we still here we're
still able to
you know to have basketball and have
life and still be able to do things
positive so
we look at that we look at the good
things that happen because there's so
much bad that happens so we got to focus
on the good
you know looking at what the lakers done
on the off-season they lost a couple of
bigs they lost rondo
they got some great additions you think
they have what it takes to repeat
i mean i think the players that they
brought in are seasoned bats just like
rondo was a season that like
you know dwight howard was a season that
and i think it's a it's a chip on their
shoulders too as far as
those who've never won one and those who
have won one you know how to get shots
when you get one you want to taste it
again so
i think it's all about you know do y'all
want to go back and do it again or y'all
content with what y'all do
well um snoop i see you got the slick
rick in the back and
i guess you're trying to say the rulers
back with the lakers that's why you got
the album in the back i see the subtle
flex in there but uh question
why this is my quest you know i live in
los angeles area now i've been there
forever
over the last 12 13 years i'm
a born and raised in new yorker i never
understood the hatred between the
clippers and the lakers they
never even if the lakers are out they
won't move over
why why why please explain to us
why there could never be clipper love in
like a nation
i don't think it's so much hate i just
think it's more about you know it's a
rivalry you know they right next door to
us they're in the same building with us
they've had some great seasons but you
know they are little brothers
until they get that thing that that
hangs up top you know that's what
they're going to be and you know i love
all of the players over there their
owners they do great things in the
community so it's not personal
it's just a a business thing you know we
in our season we're about our business
and
they just so happen to be in our way in
our stadium so
it is what it is hey snoop uh
my first television job way back in 1979
was in macon georgia and you have been
spending some time in macon georgia have
you not for the go
big show yeah i'm the executive producer
of the gold big show it's coming out
this year on uh tnt tbsn true so it's
going to be a beautiful thing it's a
show with me
burke freischer uh cody jennifer nettles
and
rosario dawson there's a bunch of talent
on there it's just
it's some of the most craziest stuff
i've ever seen in my life and i'm one of
the judges on the show and uh
i think people are going to be
entertained with this as a matter of
fact we we happen to have a clip who
would imagine that
oh wow we okay we do not have a clip of
that
so i would have imagined that what we do
have a clip on
is uh is your your boxing commentary
snoop was really good hold on let's
listen to it
they say protect yourself at all times
what they say you betcha
jake paul caught irene robinson goes
face first
lord have mercy oh there's a faint from
jake
oh my god
oh jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wow nothing funny about what's happening
with nate robinson but snoop dogg is
singing the hymns
he's trying to get right
not the man the problem child proven to
be
a big problem
[Applause]
goodness and of course pick up your
people
and pick up your pizza that was
impressive
and the the bars of precious lord like
to go that deep into it
you know you're up in the church before
y'all know when somebody falls out in
church
exactly oh man
how how much fun was that for you man is
that something
that's going to continue for you yeah
actually it was a it was
it was set up to be something that we
plan on doing for the next couple years
with a trailer and
a fight club so we started something now
so we're going to have a couple of
fights that we put on annually with
those types of you know
events to make it a big event not just
the fight but performing and just great
and analysis
and just the things that we do we bring
flavor to the table
snoop i've been knowing you a long time
you showed me a lot of love ever since i
first came
to la i just want to say brother i'm
proud of you you've been through a lot i
watched you progress you're just doing
great things in community you're doing
great things in business
so as as a true friend i just want to
say i'm proud of you brother
and i'm happy for you know how much i
love you and the family i'm proud of you
and your boys do you doing a great job
daddy
one more thing as we as we were looking
at the boxing video
uh you know we had a heavyweight bout
once upon a time with the two guys who
are on the corners of this
of this set uh would you would you like
to
try your hand at calling the shaquille
o'neal charles barkley
rumble let's look at that let's get it
oh my god jack though oh no he didn't
watch out it's a one two punch chuck
goes for the upper duck upper duck
pixie moth dropped him on the floor no
problem
tactics on the floor
[Laughter]
we sure appreciate your time enjoy the
night man as the lakers get their rings
and again
you've been a long time friend of this
show and you're welcome any time thanks
man
i love y'all man keep up the great work
man let's have a great productive season
man thank you adam silva for what you
did for the league man letting the
brothers do what we do hello
there it is that's a living legend right
there brother